you're live Shannon
thank you
good evening and welcome to this
Northwest area planning meeting uh held
today 30th of November 2022. my name is
councilor Maddie Thompson I'm the
chairman of this committee before we
commence the business of the meeting
there are just a few housekeeping rules
to run through we're streaming this
meeting live as well as recording and by
being present in the meeting you're
giving your consent to being recorded
when invited to speak please turn on
your microphone and speak clearly
referencing a page or a paragraph number
when referring to the agenda papers keep
your contributions as clear and concise
as possible and ensure your microphones
remain off when not speaking as this is
important for the live streaming to be
heard clearly finally can I draw your
attention to the notices on the agenda
papers regarding the different levels
within the chamber and advise that the
fire exit is the door behind this top
table
right members there is no Memphis update
this evening so item two is apologies
for absence please miss Casey
thank you very much item three is the
minutes it's recommended that the
minutes of the meeting held on the 2nd
of November found on pages seven to ten
are approved as a true and accurate
record may I take them as red members
getting ahead I so propose can I have a
second of please okay do we agree those
members are there any matters arising um
matters of accuracy sorry no
okay
right next item four is Declarations of
interest to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other registerable interests
and non-registerable interests relating
to items of business on the agenda
having regard to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members and members are reminded they're
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise to the meeting
anything no right thank you so item five
on the agenda is a first planning
application which is eastcroft Cottage
fanbridge Road London
and presenter is Miss Sadler please
thank you chair this application seeks
retrospective list of building consent
for internal alterations the proposed
Works relates solely to the interior of
the house
the house has been refurbished and
extended following enlisted building
consent granted in 2018 reference
701469 whilst making a routine site
visit the conservation officer noticed
that there were there had been a minor
deviation from the approved plans
internally a slightly wide opening had
been created between the kitchen and
utility room when compared to that
approved in 2018
well this was a breach of listing
building consent it has
resulted in only a small loss of the
19th century Timber structure the
conservation officer therefore advised
the owner that Smith's retrospective
application to regularize the situation
this is the location plan
some site plan
so it's the area in Orange that is the
part of the partition wall that had been
removed the areas in red at the top of
the plant are formerly previously
approved application in 2018 and not
part of this application
this is the application site
this is the before this is the photo
taken in 2015 before the opening and
this is the widened opening
and that is the end of the presentation
thank you thank you chair
um okay members
discussion time out of which I hope a
proposal will yeah I I would just say
that I I know this house very well I
used to be the former owner Trudy and
it's flooded multiple times and to be
honest I'm really impressed that the
owners have managed to save it because
there was a time when everybody thought
it was not not savable and for me it's
such a minor application I propose that
we agree the office recommendation to
approve
thank you anyone wish to speak against
those in the favor
there's only one that's got to be the
fastest application we've ever heard
okay I think that probably is some kind
of a record just for the record the
application is approved in line with the
officer's recommendation right thank you
very much the next item is our second
and last planning application
um which is Hawkins Farm Hackman's Lane
cop Clarks
this presentation please
yes
thank you chair
this application seeks permission for an
outline planning application with all
matters reserved for the demolition of
the existing dwelling and the
construction of two new dwelling houses
the application site is located on the
western side of Hackman's Lane within
the Divine settlement boundary of [ __ ]
clerks the application site is located
on a prominent Corner location on a main
thorough there leading through [ __ ]
Clarks the site is bound by dense
vegetation and mature trees there is an
existing Bungalow located at the site
and there is a mixture of Residential
Properties located along Hackman's Lane
as well as Hawkins close including
detached and semi-detached two-story
dwellings
dwellings largely front Hackman's Lane
with the exception of Hawkins close
which is a small cul-de-sac located west
of the site outline planning permission
with all matters reserved is sought for
the residential of two uh dwellings
the location plan
sites outlined in red
this is the exist Insight plan
the proposed site plan which with no
house
these are the site photographs
is there sorry oh sorry there's a few
more
oh and that's the end of the
presentation
and the recommendation oh sorry the
recommendation is proposed the proposed
development would be remote and
disconnected from local services and
Facilities by reasons of its location
and we provide poor quality and limited
access to sustainable and public
transportation resulting in an increased
need of private vehicle ownership for
future occupiers of the site it was also
result in a cramped and contrived form
of development which would not reflect
the spacious pattern of development
within the area and would result in
undue harm to the residential immunity a
future occupies by reason of direct
overlooking from number five Hawkins
close
the proposed The Proposal would lead to
the intensification of the of the across
of the access along Hackman's Lane which
would result in an unacceptable degree
of Hazard to all Road users to the
detriment of General Highway Safety and
insufficient information has been
submitted to demonstrate that there
would not be significant harm
on the impact of the trees and the
visual immunity of the locality The
Proposal would therefore be contrary to
policies S1 S2 S8 D1 D2 H4 and T2 of the
modern local development plan and is
recommended for refusal there are seven
reasons of refusal that are detailed in
the officer report
thank you all right members again we
have no member of the public speaking on
this so discussion
I don't mind going first actually to be
fair when I call this committee to
committee I thought that it was
um development of the field of the road
and I've now realized being here tonight
that it's not it's actually
um just an additional house on
um any existing residential site now is
the whole site residential already that
they're looking to put in Plymouth
Minnesota I'm a bit blindsided I don't
know why I thought it was filming it's
because the previous application was the
field I'm a bit surprised now um so is
it the is the entire site
um already residential
um that's my first question and
um
are they two-story houses are they
Bungalows what are they proposing or is
it just outline completely so we don't
know what they are at all I believe it's
completely outline
um
thank you chairman um yeah the
application is uh outline in nature um
the site yet is the opposite report
explains and some sad to say you know
that patience demolished exist in
Bungalow and to provide two dwellings on
the site so the uh
to say is it all residential as it is it
a property with Garden yes then that
would be the answer to that
um
yeah okay sorry just the clarity I think
I know the answer to this but that means
the dwellings could be anything houses
all bungalowels protection uh at the
moment yeah obviously no obviously if
members oh the LPA had strict uh for
example if you're in an area it was
really uniform Bungalows for example
someone came in with an outline and you
thought the principal uh provided dwell
on that started to accept we'd normally
impose a condition requiring that it
could only be single story
um or if you had an issue in relation to
a dorm of potential for overlooking you
might put the windows couldn't be there
are restrictions you can put in through
an outline to tie the uh Reserve matters
but we there's nothing with us where
they're proposed that thank you chairman
thank you very much right I've got
Council keys and then counselor
oh thank you
so it's up that track by the side of
them trees is that correct for that
white guy that gray brown guy you can do
any end
no right
well we've got a picture of that
sorry three year Chad that's a
neighboring the next door property I
mean Brown gate right so how did you get
to this property
the one on the left-hand side right
where the fir tree is in
so it goes up there to this one property
is that right
correct yes no yes
oh there we go so the house is in the
middle now the access is at the bottom
of that picture where the tree is no yes
because I can't make it natalities
is it I think
bye
so we don't know where the the access is
and yes no I don't think even that's
It Go on Mrs Fleming the access actually
is you drive along councilor Keys you
have the long straight bit yes before
you get to the bed it's on the bend
right so if you've got the pub
um
which is why Essex highways yeah and
usually for them have said it is not
acceptable but it already applies there
one house and I want to put two in yeah
right okay I can't remember
no I can't no it's very surprising very
surprising so that whole red outline is
the whole plot owned by the applicant
that's all in these little hers no right
37 as you can see up there this is the
existing site so yeah this is where the
property one house in the middle yeah
oh well I can't say too much before can
we go back to the pictures again then
please
and we got a picture of this head house
that's coming down
but will they like to take down no no
there is it
it's a big Bungalow sat in the middle of
a site and we'll knock it down and put
two houses in
right okay
um just just um
more interest Essex highways
have said it's not acceptable to the
highway Authority for the following
reasons The Proposal would lead to the
intensification of use of the existing
vehicular access where the required
vehicular
visibility displays of 2.4 meters by 43
meters in both directions to the near
side cannot be achieved
lack of suitable visibility
approaching Vehicles would result in an
unacceptable degree of Hazard to all
Road users to the detriment of General
Highway Safety to be put to if you put
two x two dwellings there you've double
the traffic sorry I've got Council
Fleming I've also got councilor Morley
of course
um pearly Parish Council also
um they comment on the access
to an egress from the site is on a blind
Bend and therefore represents a danger
to highway safety via increased traffic
movements at a highly dangerous location
contrary to policies T1 and T2 of the
local developments
but it's the sort of access if you asked
to put it there now you wouldn't get
permission that it's been there forever
sorry can I let councilor Morley go
because he's been sitting there very
that's okay it was thank you madam
chairman it was on
I've just get so afraid if it's not
Cruella Council um
mine also was about the access where
exactly it was going to come out of but
obviously they're sharing similar
access as you say
um trimming back the trees
though that wouldn't help that was my
thing but I do see the point that was I
mean I do know that corner and it is
quite a shot
um
yeah I'll take your point thank you
if the issue is in relation to trimming
batteries things like that then the
higher authority wouldn't normally
object they'd say that because they'd be
doing it on a plan Etc and then we would
have to deal with that so it when they
object it's because of the topography or
the angle of the camber of the road Etc
or just physical structures result in it
not being able to be met thank you Jim
like us if we can
if it could be mitigated by conditions
then they don't object the same as we
don't right so I I have got councilor
keys and Council Miss White so
no need to come back because councilor
Morley still more Thunder about cutting
the truth back I thought I haven't got a
problem if the choice could be cut back
if they can't and I always have looked
at it well thank you Council Miss White
yeah I have to say I I didn't
um
see obviously I've been out for the last
God knows how long for various super
meetings I hadn't seen the uh objection
by highways
um but I don't imagine that there's
anything stopping the applicant moving
the access to somewhere else that
highways wouldn't object to
um in in another application
um because personally for me it's
already residential so that's not the
issue but if there's a problem so I ask
the question but if there's a problem if
highways have objected then I think
that's the problem that we have
um barring it comes back with something
that highways do find acceptable and
maybe the applicant could work with
highways to try and find a solution
somewhere along the line because I think
if I was objected we didn't we can't
approve it
um I wouldn't want it on my conscience I
must admit no no exactly
um
Council Morgan
well frankly just uh thinking but it
just strikes me that um
the uh both the comments and the
recommendations from the parish council
and particularly from Essex County
Council a highways Department I I move
that this we follow officers
recommendations and refuse this
application
thank you members um yes I mean how how
often do Parish councils complain that
they take a view on these things and
don't get any support well it's highways
highways don't get the support from
highways the highways so right we have a
proposal and seconded to approve the
officer's recommendation to approve
those in favor
anyone against
okay
um
Miss Casey did you get that okay the
voting we just had won against everyone
else four did you want to say something
yes thank you okay thank you so
um again that um that application is
refused in in line with the officer's
recommendation and that brings us to
item seven any other items of business
the chairman of the committee decides
are Urgent uh you'll be very glad to
hear there are none so with thanks to
officers members and members of the
public I closed the meeting at
748 and that's some kind of record thank
you everyone well
[Music]